they give you this um
this polynomial
and they tell you
that the coefficients there
are all real which turns out to be
really important for later on okay
and then they tell you a zero
um they say minus one
is zero of the polynomial so far so good
right
so then they want you to show a result
about um
one of the roots actually i need to
borrow the questions
yeah okay so they say
this is part one right they say let
alpha be a root
okay
from which we can infer it's a cubic so
it has two other roots right um because
it's degree three right so i might as
well say um alpha and b dot and then i
don't need to say gaba because i know
what the third one is right okay so let
them be
the roots okay now the quickest path to
get to the reciprocal is to say all
right
what combines all three of those roots
in the most success way and the answer
is product of roots okay so you can say
alpha times beta times
gamma
which is
negative alpha beta right that should be
uh negative d on a right
negative
d
on a
right
i know what they say let this be the
root i know what this is so i want to
determine what this is right so then you
look at this and you're like all i have
to do is divide through
the negatives cancel so there you go
okay so now i can say all right this is
not just beta this is one on alpha right
okay now when you get to part two here's
where the fun begins now there's a
really important idea here um first they
say okay alpha is complex right sorry
it's not real it's not real which for
which intensive purposes they mean it's
complex right
so
the really key idea that you need is
well the fancy name is the conjugate
root theorem okay conjugate root here
okay it's got a fancy name but it's a
very very simple idea and i'll get you
to actually help me i'll give you some
concrete examples of this and i'll get
you to follow along
how we were taught before like
do you yeah why
okay i have to show you i have to show
you it's actually really really critical
because um it's understanding it which
helps you use it properly yeah okay so
let me give you a simple version
simplify version which actually i think
is more helpful and simpler um than the
formal one which comes under complex
numbers the conjugate root theorem
actually applies to all roots not just
complex ones in germ terms all it means
is
when a polynomial right
if it has more than one root right so if
it has
has two or more
roots sorry yeah two or more okay
if it has more than one root then the
roots are in pairs
or the roots can be paired up
um every time without exception
okay and this is actually very very
obvious when you think about it okay so
classic example if i just gave you this
one okay simple one so this has more
than one root right now i gave you an
easy one because you can factorize it
right so x plus two x plus three
but if you couldn't factorize it what
would you do you'd go to the formula
right and you'd say x equals minus b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac on 2a so clearly you
can see you can see
they're conjugates of of a kind right
now that's that's degree 2. let's go up
to degree three okay i'll just give you
a quick example
so here's here's one i made early just
so i could illustrate it clearly okay um
here's one
right now
this is my way of showing that
any arrangement of a polynomial which
has more than one root okay you can
always pair them up somehow now i
designed this polynomial so it just so
happens that um that one is a zero of
this one's a zero okay so um p of one is
equal to zero so to find out how it
factorizes right i'll i'll divide
through so let's quickly do that we'll
do synthetic because it's bigger right
so you've got one one five two negative
eight okay so walk me through it um
you should it's gonna save you a lot of
time okay um one times one one six six
times one six eight eight remainder zero
okay so x squared plus six x plus eight
is what i'll have left
so i can express this original
polynomial as x minus one because one's
the zero
x squared plus six x plus eight
okay so again you're like look i have a
root and then this one is just like i
had before so i could pair these
all right now in this case they're all
real but even when they're not and
here's where the the complex version of
the conjugate ethereum comes in right
you can still do the parent okay so
here's a more tricky one right and this
one i'll actually ask you to do with me
okay so it looks it looks simpler but
it's actually worse
okay i think that's what we've got okay
so it's nice and easy
again again one is a zero okay because
you're like one plus one minus two okay
so let's divide through on this one okay
um one is the zero my coefficients are
one one zero negative two
okay the numbers are really easy so you
write down the first one
multiply
add
multiply
add
multiply add remainder zero just like we
expected so you've got this guy
as what's left okay so now this i can
write like so
okay now unlike here you look and you're
like um
factorizing
so then you have to do this business
right okay so you say all right for this
particular part of it right i'll say x
is equal to minus b plus or minus the
square root of
b squared minus
four
ac
right
hold on
oh sorry that should be a two i was like
my numbers aren't working
yeah i don't know what i expected that
should be a four
that's more like it okay
oh of course there we go yeah which is
better actually okay because you can see
here you've got your minus two that's
going to be negative 4
negative 4
yep
all on 2
so i take out the square root of 4 there
which leaves you with
this
yes great okay
good you have to check them all right so
so
you can see clearly just like just like
here right i can pair them
here i can pair them now if what you get
out of here is paired if one of them is
complex clearly the other one must be
complex right which is where the whole
the conjugate theorem formally states if
you have real roots just like i sorry
real coefficients
like i do for all of these examples okay
and if you have a complex root if you
know one of them is complex which we do
then it's complex
it's complex conjugate must also be
one of the words does that make sense
and it's not arbitrary that it's the
complex conjugate it's the quadratic
theme um formula that's giving you
supplying
it's not always a complex quantity it's
some other conjugate but in our case
okay so now we can solve the question
right that's that's the piece that we
needed
so
the nice elegant way of saying it is
right
this is a bit of a mess
um alpha is complex
okay
so therefore the roots are not just
negative one alpha and one on alpha
right the complex conjunct conjugate
alpha
bar right must also be one of these
roots okay now
i wonder what an alpha
hold on still the same polynomial right
this time it's a complex
yes but it's still the same scenario
isn't it it hasn't changed
uh negative one is still one of the is
it still a zero
alpha is still a zero but alpha's
complex
okay
yes the conjugate
yes that's right so one of these must be
alpha bar okay now alpha can't be alpha
bar yeah right because by the way you
know z can equal z bar on one condition
think about it
if a plus b i was equal to a minus b i
what would that mean
it would be no imaginary part right so
in this the only way of this being the
case is if z is real but we just said
that alpha's not real so alpha can't be
alpha bar negative one is not alpha plus
so this must be alpha okay okay so we
say one on alpha
must equal alpha bar
okay
cool all right now to go from there to
get to what we want you multiply through
by alpha so you're getting alpha times
alpha bar equals one
now
what is this
if you can't remember
right alpha times alphabet let's
actually let's actually put some um some
numbers on this right so this is one
complex number times its conjugate
right so this is difference of squares
but not because that i is going to make
it not the difference of squares but the
sum of squares right so this is a
squared plus
b squared but you recognize that you
recognize that that is the modulus
of alpha isn't it
because when you've got
alpha
he's um
he's alpha up here at a plus b i
right so you've got
a down here
and b down here
right so
in this case here
c squared equals a squared plus a b
squared right
so what you have here is the square root
sorry i should have said the square the
square of the modulus
right
um so what you've got here now is you
can say you can actually go straight
there you don't have to go through all
of this you can say i recognize that
that is
i'm sorry going across here
that's the modulus of alpha
squared c squared right that's equal to
one as required
okay
so it's a bit of a
from here to here it's not clear without
saying where did that all come from and
it came from what does it mean when you
multiply a complex number by its
conjugate and what do you get at the end
the answer is you get the square of the
modulus
okay